>>> AS WE CONTINUE "SPRING INTO
SUMMER" WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW TO
TRAVEL SAFELY.
THE TSA SCREENED THE MOST
PASSENGERS IN 14 MONTHS.
L
LET'S GO TO NEWARK LIBERTY
AIRPORT.
TWO OF OUR EXPERTS ARE INSIDE A
UNITED AIRLINES PLANE, DR. JON
LaPOOK AND OUR SENIOR TRAVEL
ADVISER PETER GREENBERG.
THEY'RE BOTH WEARING MASKS TO
FOLLOW UNITED'S POLICY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU BOTH.
JON, LET ME START WITH YOU.
MASKS ARE STILL REQUIRED FOR
FULLY VACCINATED PASSENGERS ON
PLANES.
WHY IS THAT?
>> GOOD MORNING, ANTHONY.
IT'S BASICALLY TO PROTECT PEOPLE
WHO ARE EITHER UNVACCINATED OR
VACCINATED BUT FOR SOME REASON
THEY DIDN'T GET AN ADEQUATE
IMMUNE RESPONSE TO THE VACCINE.
FOR EXAMPLE, SOMEBODY WHO'S
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED.
IN THAT SCENARIO INSIDE OF A
PLANE AND PEOPLE AREN'T WEARING
MASKS, IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T WEAR
A MASK AND THEY'RE INFECTED,
THEY POSE A DANGER TO OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> PETER, EVERY STATE HAS
DIFFERENT RESTRICTIONS AT THIS
POINT ON COVID.
SO WHAT SHOULD YOU KEEP IN MIND
AS YOU'RE TRAVELING?
>> WELL, FIRST, YOU CAN ALWAYS
GO TO THE CDC'S WEBSITE TO SEE
WHAT EACH STATE IS DOING.
THE REALITY, ANTHONY, IS THAT
VERY FEW STATES HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR THE STAFF TO
ENFORCE THOSE GUIDELINES, LET
ALONE MONITOR THEM.
WE'RE MORPHING INTO AN HONORS
SYSTEM WHERE INDIVIDUAL PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS IS KEY.
I'M LESS CONCERNED ABOUT FLYING
TO A DESTINATION NOW THAN I AM
ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR OF THE PEOPLE
IN THIS DESTINATION.
>> WHERE WOULD YOU SUGGEST THAT
PEOPLE GO TO LOOK FOR GLOBAL
TRAVEL AS FAR AS WHAT EACH
COUNTRY, CONTINENT, STATE, IS
REALLY REQUIRING, OR DOESN'T
HAVE OPEN YET -- WHERE DO YOU GO
TO KNOW?
>> WELL, WHAT YOU LOOK FOR, OF
COURSE, IS THEIR OWN WEBSITES
FROM THEIR OWN CONSULATES.
THEY'LL GIVE YOU
STATE-OF-THE-ART CUTTING EDGE
INFORMATION.
IT CHANGES ALMOST HOURLY.
GREECE OPENED YESTERDAY.
ITALY'S OPENING TODAY.
FRANCE MAY BE OPENING LATER THIS
WEEK.
THE SAME APPLIES IN THE REST OF
THE 48 CONTINENTAL U.S.
>> IN ORDER TO GET THERE, JON,
MOST PEOPLE HAVE TO GET ON A
PLANE, AND PEOPLE ARE STILL
WORRIED ABOUT THE VENTILATION.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
VENTILATION, HOW SAFE IT IS?
I THINK MANY PEOPLE, BY PEOPLE I
MEAN ME, MANY PEOPLE NEED
REASSURANCE ABOUT THE
VENTILATION ON THE PLANES.
IT'S STILL SCARY TO ME.
>> HI, YOU SHOULD BE REASSURED.
I DID A DEEP DIVE ON THIS.
AND VENTILATION ON PLANES LIKE
THIS IS EXCELLENT.
ABOUT HALF OF THE AIR COMES FROM
THE OUTSIDE.
IT'S COMBINED WITH RECIRCULATED
AIR.
IT ALL GOES THROUGH HEPA
AFFIRMATIVE THAT GET RID OF
VIRAL -- FILTERS THAT GET RID OF
VIRUSES.
IT COMES FROM THE CEILING TO THE
FLOOR, COMES OUT OF VENTS.
IF YOU WANT A TRICK, YOU OPEN UP
THE AIR VENT ABOVE YOU, HAVE IT
FLOW RIGHT ON YOU TO HELP
DISPERSE AIR.
THE AIR IS COMPLETELY EXCHANGED
ABOUT EVERY THREE MINUTES WHICH
IS BETTER THAN IN SOME MEDICAL
SETTINGS.
>> FIRST THING I DO IS TURN OFF
THE VENT BECAUSE THE SOUND
BOTHERS ME.
THIS AIR BLOWING DOWN ON ME IS
ANNOYING.
>> I DON'T LIKE THE FEELING
ALSO.
>> TURN ON THE VENTS.
>> OKAY.
GOOD ADVICE.
>> DR. GREENBERG, I'D LOVE TO
ASK WHY DELTA'S THE ONLY AIRLINE
THAT IS STILL HAVING AN EMPTY
MIDDLE SEAT AND WHY OTHER
AIRLINES FEEL THAT THEY CAN
PROCEED AT FULL CAPACITY.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, FIRST, FOR
CALLING ME DR. GREENBERG.
I'M GOING TO HOLD THAT AGAINST
DR. LaPOOK LATER.
>> SORRY.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS -- DELTA
IS NO LONGER BLOCKING THE
PRESIDENT CMIDDLE
SEAT.
THEY STOPPED APRIL 30th.
I'M STANDING HERE ONLY ABOUT
THREE FEET AWAY FROM DR. LaPOOK.
THAT'S NOT SIX FEET OF
SEPARATION.
AIRLINE CABINS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE FILLING EVERY
SEAT ON EVERY AVAILABLE PLANE.
>> PETER, TALK ABOUT TRAVEL
TRENDS THAT YOU'RE SEEING.
AND ESPECIALLY WE WERE ALL
SITTING AT THE TABLE TALKING
ABOUT HOW HARD IT IS AND HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS TO GET A RENTAL
CAR.
TALK ABOUT THE TRAVEL TRENDS,
PLEASE.
>> SURE.
WELL, TALKING ABOUT THE RENTAL
CARS, IT'S BAD.
I JUST -- I GOT AN ESTIMATE FOR
A RENTAL CAR IN FLORIDA, IT'S
$441 A DAY.
THAT DOESN'T -- THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE DROP-OFF CHARGES,
THE MILEAGE CAPS, AND GOD FORBID
YOU HAVE TO LET THEM REFUEL THE
CAR, COULD BE AS MUCH AS $11 A
GALLON.
WHAT YOU NEED DO IS RENT A CAR
MIDWEEK, DO NOT RENT IT AT THE
AIRPORT.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO RETURN IT WITH
NO DROP-OFF CHARGE.
BUT TRIPS OF UNDER 500 MILES, DO
YOURSELF A FAVOR, IT'S BYOC,
BRING YOUR OWN CAR.
>> PETER, HOW CROWDED ARE THE
AIRLINES EXPECTED IT'S GOING TO
BE THIS SUMMER?
ARE WE CLOSE TO GETTING BACK TO
PRE-PANDEMIC LEVELS?
>> EVERYONE ON THE PLANES AND
EVERY AIRPLANE IS UNPARKED,
THEY'RE IN THE SKIES.
THE AIRLINES HAVE ADDED 170 NEW
ROUTES IN THE UNITED STATES
ALONE.
IN MANY CASES, THEY'RE ALL
OUTDOOR DESTINATIONS, CLOSE TO
STATE AND NATIONAL PARKS.
THE ONE EXAMPLE IS BOZEMAN,
MONTANA.
THEY ADDED 200,000 SEATS TO THAT
AIRPORT.
IT'S THE FASTEST GROWING AIRPORT
IN THE UNITED STATES.
NOW DO THEY HAVE 200,000 ROOMS
IN BOZEMAN?
THEY DON'T.
IT MAY BE INEXPENSIVE TO GET
THERE, WATCH YOUR WALLET AS TO
HOW EXPENSIVE IT'S GOING TO BE
TO BE THERE.
>> DR. LaPOOK, QUICKLY, WHAT'S
THE ONE THING, THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING PEOPLE SHOULD
BRING WHEN THEY TRAVEL?
>> BEST THING TO BRING IS THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
VACCINATED.
AND ON TOP OF THAT, YOUR COMMON
SENSE, OKAY.
>> OKAY.
>> FIGURE OUT WHAT THE RISK IS
IN AREAS.
SO THE POTENTIAL ACHILLES HEEL
OF THE CDC GUIDELINES IS YOU'RE
IN AN INDOOR SETTING, THE
VENTILATION'S NOT GREAT, IT'S
CROWDED, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
THERE WHO ARE NOT WEARING MASKS.
NOW, IF THAT PERSON IS NOT
WEARING A MASK, POTENTIALLY THEY
COULD BE INFECTED, NOT
VACCINATED.
AND A POTENTIAL DANGER TO INFECT
OTHER PEOPLE.
IN THAT SETTING, I THINK
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED AT INCREASED
RISK, TRY TO STAY AWAY FROM
THOSE SETTINGS OR GET THE BEST
POSSIBLE MASKS YOU CAN.
I THINK IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE
INDOORS TO WEAR AN N9